krisenzeiten das sind eigentlich kanzler
zeiten zeiten in denen einst ganz
besonders gebraucht und gefordert wird
nämlich führung aber stattdessen erleben
wir seit wochen ein hin und her in der
frage nach waffenlieferungen für die
ukraine verzögerung ein zaudern und das
inmitten einer neuen flüchtlingskrise
und inmitten einer tiefen inflations
krise das sind sorgen zeiten und
inmitten dieser sorgen zeiten will ein
mann eine wahl gewinnen in
nordrhein-westfalen dieser mann nämlich
hendrik wüst der amtierende
ministerpräsident des
bevölkerungsreichsten bundeslandes grüße
sie herzlich hier in den richtigen
fragen ministerpräsident
schon von ihrer größe sonate krieg
mittlerweile und immer noch ein hin und
her keine klare positionierung in der
frage nach der lieferung von schweren
waffen aus deutschland gleichzeitig
beziehen wir auch nach zwei monaten
weiterhin putins gas und putin zu können
sie sagen das ist das bestmögliche was
deutschland in dieser zeit tun konnte
für die ukraine
ich glaube das kann man ganz sicher
nicht sagen dass hin und her ging ja
nicht erst bei den schweren waffen los
es war bei swift schon so bei dem
zahlungsverkehr es war bei den
sanktionen
schon so ist aber nord stream zwei so
immer das gleiche immer ein langes
zögern und zaudern deutschland droht so
isoliert zu sein im
internationalen konzert unserer freunde
und partner und das macht mir große
sorgen weil wir 70 jahre gut damit
gefahren sind gemeinsam unterwegs zu
sein mit unseren partnern und freunden
wenn wir über führungen sprechen wie
steht deutschland denn im moment ihrem
empfinden nach in der welt da also
welche welche eigenschaften verbindet
man mit deutschland stark
solidarisch hilfsbereit oder all das
gerade nicht
alles was ich aus dem ausland höhere ist
genau das gegenteil das zögern das
zaudern führt dazu dass man sich in den
augen reibt und fragt was ist mit
deutschland los ihr müsstet es gerade
hier müsste es doch besser wissen viele
verstehen nicht wie sich die
bundesregierung gerade verhält das
zögern und zaudern sorgt für viele
fragezeichen wegen all dem gibt es heute
ja gerade zum frontalangriff von
unionsfraktionschef und city friedrich
merz heute in der bild am sonntag ein
frontalangriff auf denen der führen soll
auf den kanzler auf olaf scholz aktuell
werden das in den nächsten tagen
schicksalstage für ihn für den kanzler
und für seine regierung
es jedenfalls ganz ganz wichtige tage
vor allen dingen für die menschen in der
ukraine die auf unsere hilfe angewiesen
sind und es gibt eine mehrheit im
deutschen bundestag dafür die ukraine
noch besser zu helfen und deswegen
glaube ich ist es richtig dass dort auch
zu diskutieren ja sie sprechen das an
einer abstimmung eine mögliche
abstimmung im bundestag die fdp hat das
auf dem parteitag genau gefordert
nämlich die weitere lieferung schwerer
waffen für die ukraine teile der grünen
wollen das auch vor allen dingen die
außenministerin wilders ist das eine
frage an der die ampel koalition die
regierung zerbrechen könnte
darum geht es jetzt nicht ob da eine
regierung gut oder weniger gut dasteht
es geht darum dass man hilft dass wir im
konzert mit unseren nachbarn hilft ich
sitze hier in düsseldorf wir sind ganz
in der nähe der niederlande selbst die
niederlande helfen andere in
mittelosteuropa helfen ganz konkret und
deutschland zaudert und zögert und lässt
die ukraine im stich und das ist in
dieser situation fatal denn dort werden
auch unsere werte verteidigt freiheit
frieden ja wie man ihren aussagen
deswegen ist ein anderer soldat und
klinische nicht um die regierung dann
sagen sie die es hat nicht endlich ihre
motivation jetzt die regierung zu
zerbrechen das ist schon klar aber
sozusagen kann hier der bruch in der
koalition entstehen weil die frage so
wichtig ist wenn sie es im bundestag zur
abstimmung machen die union dann besteht
dass er möglicherweise bevor das die
koalition genau an dieser frage
zerbricht also ist das möglich
es ist jedenfalls das zweite mal dass in
einer ganz wesentliche frage diese
regierung die ampel unter der führung
von olaf scholz keine mehrheit hat das
war bei der impfpflicht so eine wichtige
frage jetzt auch wieder insofern ist es
richtig das zu diskutieren
das auch im bundestag anhängig zu machen
dort gehören die diskussion auf den
tisch des hauses und ja natürlich kann
daran auch die bundesregierung
verbrechen und müsste scholz daran dass
vertrauen in ihn koppeln müsste er das
zu einer vertrauensfrage machen
das wäre sicherlich das letzte
disziplinierung mittel um die koalition
zusammenzuhalten so weit sind wir nicht
ich habe einfach anliegen und die
unions-bundestagsfraktion auch darum
geht es wenn man in der regierung keine
mehrheit findet hilft vielleicht eine
mehrheit im parlament das richtige zu
tun der ukrainische präsident seelands
gefordert ja auch genau das von
deutschland auch die lieferung von
schweren waffen jetzt in sein land an
die front in die ukraine glauben sie
dass der kanzler am ende dort seine
position noch mal verändert wird also
zustimmen wird
eine mehrheit dafür im deutschen
bundestag hätte er jedenfalls und zu den
motiven von olaf scholz müssen sie
besser ihn selber fragen haben wir auch
schon gefragt und er argumentiert ja
bisher hat dagegen dass er sagt naja
dann drohen wir in deutschland
kriegspartei zu werden dann droht uns
auch der atomkrieg jetzt liefern ihr
andere länder schwere waffen und der
atomkrieg hat bisher auch mit diesen
ländern nicht stattgefunden stimmt
dieses argument überhaupt
nein ich glaube es stimmt nicht sie
sagen es richtig sonst wären andere
länder die schwere waffen liefern ja
auch kriegspartei geworden auch der
bundesjustizminister hat das vor wenigen
tagen noch mal ganz klar anders gesagt
und dem kanzler widersprochen ich zeige
ihnen mal fotos die aktuell um die welt
gehen die zeigen einen früheren kanzler
gerd schröder der sitz dort und steht in
seiner wohnung in hannover das sind
fotos die die new york times
veröffentlicht hat mit einem langen
interview mit gerhard schröder in dem er
überhaupt keine reue zeigt sondern
stramm an der seite putins weiter steht
viele nennen das ein schamloses
interview was fällt ihnen zu diesen
fotos ein höchst
ja das interview von gerd schröder in
der new york times ist schon ziemlich
verstörend und es muss folgen haben die
gesamte spd führung hat gesagt wenn
gerhard schröder an seinen gut bezahlten
mandaten bei putin festhält kann er
nicht mehr mitglied der spd sein jetzt
sagt er uns über ein interview in der
new york times dass er genau das vor hat
nämlich seinen gut bezahlten jobs bei
putin zu behalten und deswegen ist die
spd jetzt aufgerufen ihren worten taten
folgen zu lassen hannover 96 hat den
kanzler schon ausgeschlossen was
hannover 96 kann muss auch die spd
schaffen ja oder andere versuchen gerade
den krieg zu gewinnen also es kann nicht
so schwer sein weil das ist ja das
argument vieler sozialdemokraten ja
langwieriges verfahren das ist so
umständlich da jemand raus zu kriegen
also schwer kannst dich sein oder
ja das mag sein dass diese verfahren zum
parteiausschluss langwierig sind aber
wenn man es vorher klar gesagt hat da
muss man das jetzt auch machen schröder
sagt in diesem interview er habe sich
immer für die interessen deutschlands
eingesetzt und aktuell genieße er aber
offenbar nur noch von einer seite
vertrauen der meinte ganz offenbar den
kreml meinte moskau ganz offenbar ist
tatsächlich für gerd schröder im moment
der bessere platz moskau als deutschland
ein kanzler auch ein ehemaliger kanzler
sollte immer wissen wo der richtige
platz für ihn ist er kann nur in
deutschland sein und deswegen muss er
entsprechend handeln er muss seine
mandate niederlegen um diesen
reputationsschaden nicht noch stärker
werden zu lassen
das ist ein mann der ex kanzler der
moment ja auch weiterhin nicht nur von
putin bezahlt wird sondern vom deutschen
steuerzahler also auch von ihren
potenziellen wählern in dortmund in
essen in bochum wie können sie den die
jeden tag arbeiten gehen erklären dass
ihr steuergeld zumindest ein kleiner
kleiner teil davon auch weiterhin an
diesen putin mann gerd schröder fließt
ja das kann man überhaupt nicht erklären
und deswegen sollten wir das auch ändern
wir sollten klar festlegen das ist diese
versorgung für die altkanzler auch
ehemalige bundespräsidenten nur geben
kann wenn man nicht noch von anderen
staaten geld bekommt das passt nicht
zusammen das hat es ja auch noch nie
gegeben diese schamlose verhalten und
deswegen müssen wir die regeln zu ändern
aber das sagen wir jetzt auch schon
relativ viele wochen oder sagen viele
anhänger der cdu/csu auch andere
parteien seit vielen wochen und
irgendwie passiert nichts also warum
kommt man da nicht in die gänge das kann
doch auch nicht so schwer sein wir reden
doch aktuell über weit weit weit kommt
weitere fragen als dass
ich glaube dass die spd überhaupt kein
interesse daran hat dieses thema in der
öffentlichkeit zu diskutieren aber sie
wird es ja nicht los insbesondere dann
nicht wenn gerd schröder so schamlos
weitermacht wie bisher und deswegen
muster was passieren da muss jetzt
klassisch gemacht werden nimmt der
kanzler ihrem eindruck nach aktuell in
seiner positionierung oder nicht
positionierung über die gerade schon
gesprochen haben nimmt er rücksicht auf
dieses offenbare russland netzwerken
seiner partei
also dass spd russland netzwerk der
vergangenheit ist ja unstreitig dass
gibt es offenbar auch mit starkem
einfluss bis in die heutige zeit aber
der kanzler hätte eine mehrheit im
deutschen bundestag für die richtige
politik er muss sich frei machen von
diesem russland netzwerk in der eigenen
partei ist darf ihn heute nicht daran
haben die richtigen entscheidungen zu
treffen sie sprechen dieses russland
netzwerk jetzt ganz offensiv an muss man
das nicht muss die partei das nicht
aufarbeiten sich dessen entledigen in
anderen fällen früheren fällen hat man
da historikerkommission ein gesetz muss
man sich nicht frei davon machen und das
wirklich ja aufarbeiten in den eigenen
reihen
das ist jetzt nicht an mir der spd der
ratschläge zur aufarbeitung zu geben mir
ist wichtig dass die bundesrepublik
deutschland dass die bundesregierung die
richtigen entscheidungen trifft und dazu
muss der bundeskanzler sich freimachen
von all diesen hemmnissen die es da
offensichtlich aus diesen russischen
netzwerk in der spd gibt jetzt sind sie
morgen mit dem bundeskanzler zusammen
mit olaf scholz und wollen etwas von
chemie streiten immer noch um die
verteilung von flüchtlings kosten von
aufgaben zwischen bund ländern und
kommunen
haben sie den eindruck dass die
flüchtlingskrise dies ja ja
unzweifelhaft wiedergibt seit zwei
monaten dass wir die in deutschland im
griff haben
also die finanzierungsfrage haben wir in
der letzten runde geklärt da haben wir
durchgesetzt habe auch ich als
vorsitzender mpk zwei milliarden euro
für die länder für die kommunen vom bund
geholt das ist erstmal okay
wiedervorlage im herbst wenn wir sehen
wie die zahlen sich entwickelt haben
worum geht es um das thema integration
und da ist besonders wichtig dass wir
nicht putins job erledigen hier alle
menschen die von putins krieg fliehen
sind bei uns herzlich willkommen bei uns
schutz zu finden und wir müssen alle
anstrengungen machen sie zu integrieren
dass die kinder hier ankommen können
dass ihnen die schule in die kitas hier
ist eine große anstrengung von ländern
kommunen von zivilgesellschaft da wird
viel großartiges geleistet aber wir
müssen auch auf einen zweiten punkt
achten putin will das ukrainische volk
mit all seiner identität und kultur
zerstören und dabei dürfen wir nicht
mitmachen deswegen ist mir ganz
besonders wichtig dass wir die
ukrainische kulturarbeit stärken auch
bei den menschen die jetzt zu uns kommen
angebote machen ihnen die möglichkeit
geben ihre ukrainische
identität zu pflegen auch wenn sie
vielleicht etwas länger hier bleiben
vielleicht sogar dauerhaft hierbleiben
müssen sonst hätte putin am ende
gewonnen oder das ist aber wahnsinnig
schwierig herr ministerpräsident sie
sitzen daher vor dem dilemma eigentlich
einerseits wollen wir alle dass die
menschen vor allen dingen für sie selbst
dass sie so schnell wie möglich
zurückkommen wieder in ihre
möglicherweise oder in weiten teilen
mittlerweile zerstörte heimat und
andererseits wollen wir natürlich so
schnell wie möglich integrieren aber wie
viele integration ist in diesem dilemma
tatsächlich für all die menschen für die
kinder und frauen überhaupt sinnvoll
ja ich weiß auch viele wollen
zurückkehren in ihre heimat und das ist
auch gut so das würde uns ja genauso
gehen wenn wir fliegen müssten deswegen
wollen ja auch viele menschen die
fliehen möglichst nah an ihrer heimat
bleiben das ist alles okay aber wenn sie
wenn sie hier ist sollten wir sie nicht
einfach in großen unterkünften warten
lassen bis klar ist ob sie zurückkommen
sondern angebote der integration machen
auch integrationen in den arbeitsmarkt
ist ja möglich mit den regeln die wir
jetzt in deutschland verabredet haben
der wichtige punkt ist dabei dass die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer bleiben
können wir kennen das von vielen anderen
menschen die zu uns gekommen sind die
geschichte meines landes nordrhein
westfalens ist reich an zuzug an
menschen die aus ihren ländern zu uns
gekommen sind sie haben sich integriert
aber auch ein stück ihrer identität
behalten und das möchte ich den menschen
die aus der ukraine zu uns kommen auch
ermöglichen nachweis einer praktischen
ministerpräsident schule fängt wieder an
nach den osterferien und das wird jetzt
der erste größere schwung seien von
kindern aus der ukraine die dann auch
tatsächlich in den klassen sitzen haben
sie den eindruck dass unsere schulen
dass ihre schulen dass ihre kitas
richtig gut drauf vorbereitet sind schon
ja es ist natürlich eine herausforderung
in größeren städten gibt es willkommens
klassen in kleineren orten sind es
manchmal nur ein zwei kinder die dann
eine schule in eine klasse gehen
natürlich ist es eine herausforderung
die lehrerinnen und lehrer die wissen
schon dass das keine kleinigkeit ist und
trotzdem müssen wir uns der mühe
unterziehen müssen wir den kindern ein
angebot machen hier in deutschland in
die schule zu gehen damit sie ankommen
damit sie auch kontakte knüpfen damit
sie die deutsche sprache lernen aber sie
sollen dabei eben nicht ihre
muttersprache verlieren sie sollen nicht
ihre identität und ihre kultur verlieren
jetzt bietet sich hier in berlin auch in
vielen anderen bundesländern ein problem
das man erstmal natürlich guckt wer kann
hier die sprache sprechen wer kann hier
zumindest russisch sprechen und oft sind
das dann ja mittlerweile mit deutschem
pass versehene russlanddeutsche also
ursprünglich russin die ihr zu klinische
kinder unterrichten sollen oder dort in
den kitas erziehen sollen finden sie das
eine gute idee ursprünglich russen und
russen jetzt mit den ukrainischen
kindern arbeiten zu lassen
ja dann natürlich muss man da sensibel
sein aber ich war noch sehr davor alle
menschen die aus russland kommen
deutschrussen russen jetzt über einen
kamm zu scheren
da sind auch sehr sehr viel dabei die
diesen krieg sehr sehr kritisch sehen
und da muss man glaube ich sehr genau
differenzieren
und nicht nicht alle gleich in eine ecke
stellen das war überhaupt nicht mein
vorhaben die frage ist nur wie man das
praktisch löst also diejenigen in
deutschland die sprache können die
kommen möglicherweise ja aus anderen
gründen auch aus politischen gründen
nicht in frage oder ist dass bisher kein
problem bei ihnen
also es ist jedenfalls kein so großes
problem dass wir da gleich eine ganze
gruppe ausschließen sollten wer hier als
erzieherin als erzieherin arbeitet er
muss ja erstmal ausgebildet sein wir
sind da jetzt natürlich auf flexibilität
angewiesen ist kommen ja auch viele
erzieherinnen erzieher lehrerinnen und
lehrer aus der ukraine zu uns so dass
ich auch glaube dass wir dort aus diesem
personal reservoir wenn man so will noch
wird schöpfen können sie haben gerade
gesagt die finanzierungsfrage die sah ja
jetzt erst mal abgeräumt tatsächlich gab
es die einigung in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz aber viele
kommunen sagen das reicht noch nicht wir
haben hier in den vergangenen wochen
auch immer vertreter von städten auch
aus dormagen zum beispiel hier gehabt
die gesagt mensch das geld ist noch
nicht hier und so und selbst jetzt sagen
viele vertreter der kommunen reicht noch
nicht die fordern 3500 euro pro
flüchtlinge und pro monat halten sie das
für realistisch
die kosten sind jeweils unterschiede da
muss man schauen für welche für welche
aufwände diese kosten daher berechnet